في أعماق الغابة في الجبهة الشرقية لأوكرانيا ،
تحفر القوات في
الخنادق هنا منقذون للحياة
وضعناها هنا نقاتل في مناطق نقاتل فيها ،
وأخذنا نصيبنا من التحدي هنا
وبعض تجارتنا
أصيبت بوجوه القوات هنا تحكي
قصة تلك الكلمات  لا يمكن أن يكون
هذا واجبًا صعبًا
لمدة خمسة أيام في المقدمة عشرة أيام يستريحون
هنا في مكان قريب ،
فهم يمزحون حول العيش مثل الهوبيت
تحت الأرض بعيدًا عن القصف
عندما يتحدث المسؤولون الأوكرانيون عن
نظام صاروخ هايمارز ومدفعية M777 التي
تساعد في الحفاظ على خطهم
هذه
هي الخطوط التي هم عليها  نتحدث عن
هؤلاء هم الجنود الذين
يقاتلون بشدة للتأكد من صمتهم
، يقول إننا نحافظ على الخط ،
إنه رطب ، حيث تضربنا القذائف
طوال الوقت ، لكننا نحافظ على الدفاع ،
ولا توجد طريقة أخرى
بالطبع للقصف على سيارتك  يخبرني العقل
أرتيم أن صديقه الحيوي مضيفًا ، لكنك تعتاد
على ذلك على
حد سواء عند الانتصار ، ويقولون
للوصول إلى خط المواجهة ، نعبر
الحقول المليئة بالصواريخ الروسية
كل هذه الأشياء.  يخبروننا هنا
أنهم قد أخرجوا من
ظروف القصف هنا حيث
كان الروس على بعد أقل من ميل واحد على بعد
أيام هنا عندما لا تستطيع القوات مغادرة
مخابئها ، روسيا تطلق النار عليهم خمس مرات ،
وهذا هو المكان الذي ستكون فيه المرحلة التالية من
الحرب  ربحنا أو خسرنا في خنادق مثل
هذه التي تمتد لمئات الأميال
مثل هذه القوات التي تصمد
أمام التقدم الروسي المحتمل
الذي نديره ، يقول الضابط
أننا جئنا إلى هنا لإيقاف العدو ،
فنحن نخرجه ونستمر في
قتال  قذيفة واردة تتخلل تفكيره
المزيد من الأسلحة المزيد من الأسلحة والدروع التي يقولها
ويمكن أن يكون لنا أن نتقدم
لك